こんにちははじめ冊遊べるに各校に来たんですけども
中学校を致しますね僕が中学校の時中にまではめちゃくちゃ頭が悪くて100点中16
点とかの蹄跡だったんですけども
そこからなんか塾とかに通って覚醒して
中2位の終わりぐらいからずっとずっと額でトップ l にずっと居たっていう思い出
があっ
ます今回は皆さんスタディーサプリというものをご紹介したいと思いますした d
サプリは食べるってパソコンなので勉強できるオンライン学習サービスのことで超学生
中学生高校生を対象としたサービスです有名なプロコースの授業動画やその他の様々な
学習のコンテンツとタブレットやパソコンなどで気軽に勉強できるスタイルとなって
おりますところで皆さん
んユーチューバー
みんな馬鹿っぽく見えませんか人のこと言えないんですけどなんで今回はちょっと言え
ば本当にバターなのかをテストができて確かめてみようと思いますでため僕の予想だと
ユーチューバーみんなバカと思うんで
この馬鹿なユーチューバーたちが2 d サプリを使って本当に行くの学力が上がるか
どうかっていうのは今がちょっと継承してみようと思います
では言おうか配球で今からおバカなユーチューバー何か4なのでちょっと実際に教室の
口に入ってもらおうと思います
hey
ござるただもアバン県の空人のするようです ir ます
はございません
ブーブですはいまーす
a ます andare a
関なる水
もう一的調和させてるんですけど
最後のひとりーはこの中ですどうぞ voodoo
ブーブー s としていきたいとおもいます
姉あーし are you do
ばセラートップの
入れ替えああああああああ
私ショパン皆さん気になるところだと思うので
実際に皆さん問題を超えていただいて本当に頭が良いのかどうかはちょっと
まずとりあえず調べていこうと思います宜しくお願いしますよろしくねああ
すごい奴はるー
えっと制限時間は10分
問題数が20問になりますこの感じ
もう約十年ぶりくらいなんですかーっお得なんですよ立っては彼にいる禁酒で
ちまうぞでは
ベストを会心譜
ana b
持っています
おっ p い
終了です
ちょっと再生してくるんで何しましょう
ですか2ん
駄文
お待たせしましたーー
ああああああ
ああまずは10位の方からうん
re dermalab
公演を発表します
2位2人ます百選中50銭
eos 20 d カラー
me
ますガンダム oo
おおおおう
良いよずよねもーんとにパスワー
5位とって四世って赤瀬 tv 等
muta
ぶーぶーっ
ビリー街の上の8番を良いは全部同じです11
ギコちゃんぽんパワーみせ
嘘はあぁそっち cure
俺を
rar
何でも得るもので動いてるわー
toranoana
だって世界を張って
ben ああああ
残っていますだれ jar
臨時発表します得でニート10点車で60点
ウーロン
またデビルー
ああああああ
re は自分でマック言いたかっはああーーーーっっっ
回答4校を交えしてたんですけど珍回答が多かった
ゆっくりみんなで見ていきましょう神回ぞ
今私たちの食べ物が元夫た本で一歩スレ
なになにーにーかードイツで待ってるん
本文前回たーーー
0敗
正解は私たちの神のものもと踊っていくとすべて
職別にたどり着けます ua
明らかに入っ
ギンガー
トランスとああああ
あそこバナー
こちららわーわー
目の問題ですあああさんもう
car
ああああああ
一つさんさあ
3時間近くでなくあげたんですけど大田じゃああー
ああああああ
ni
ちょっと絵図は床から水を吸い上げますかというか
ぎこちゃんたらのえっ今回正解でさあ
ますという意味
おっ
すごい山どこか人を吸い上げますかおいっ
car
にゃんすけよ江戸しない左の宿と感じてください本当の言い
可愛いですよ
沖中ですからねうん
ああああああああ
現在世界にはおおよそどれくらいの数の国がありますか
これ正解者2人だけですもうそこ花さんと富竹
パジェロ
んわーそれがこちら
おっ
ああああああああ
約195書く b の方も
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
こちらハイチェアー
はい美亜子は投げ件いいの全面積は約6分の1を占める
違う1
亜子ちゃんを立てうん甘い焼いてねこれでいまずは
う
日本一英藍
へいへい i t 1
あってからはぁっ
web 日間の薬草は jr
par
本当に誰かさん
うっ
でかいゴール機関の略称こちらコミュニティしヴァンドペイ
あっていた
んですねーおおおっ
ブーバーし
re
第5部位の期間いいなああああ
1の下し部にください
君破れて山河れるかあぁそんなとか全然か
サトチーさん
nar わけで突破
ああああああ
car
円に対する節電は切片を通る直径と南になるさと小さな行い成果いることだ
水族1010パーンに対する
ぜひてんだが制しているペンなんてこうまあ中ここらへんめでここを通る直線の言われ
てなんかないんです
ああああああああ
ああああああああそれでどこが競ってるんですよこれが
垂直ですかそういう
あと円柱を書きなさいって言うもっと
a オレオってさぞ
トミーゴルフで聞いてるとか頭じゃなぁ
wh
nara いって書いたんですか
23議席の角で黙る不等号を書きなさい
本当のユーリが結構
深海とですねこちら
にやりこういうああ
はっはっは次の誰も英語にしながらどうよってなく縫っ
さあ悪いああああああ
ran とに入ってっていたああわかっちゃいぞ
音一の英文を日本語に訳しなさいなんて
すべて行くよ酒なんていうの
さーああああ
という感じでございました
こちらから
皆さんには居残り勉強をしていただきたいと思っております
今回個人のスタディサプリの二人の動画があるので子連れでちょっと勉強して復習して
間違いをしっかり理解して正しい答えが入れるように勉強しましょう
re ん
ろうそくの火が消えましたこれで見れるらしい
設計士が白く人になるほどねすげーなー
これミティサージュあればずつらかにありません
ni
ありません動画はいかがだったでしょうかわかめ
立って考える力作ったので甘くないから
見やすいそう短いからいっぱいの増加が分前を見やすいという利点もあります
それゆえ
次は全員で16問連続正解するまで帰れませんゲームしまーすはい
バッハ
はいというで views バーがグループ zest いかがだったでしょうか
すごいいろんな珍回答はてなんですけども今回使った2 g サプリ中学講座では3
年間の勉強を進めて和了しております部活の両立が可能で天気雪
医学の即日パワーを持っています小学コーナーでは小学校4年生から6年生の授業を
すべて方だしています
その後
で食べるパソコンでいつでも勉強できる勉強習慣がない言葉だけでも連続して習慣に
することができますせこのストーリーサークルなんと中学コード小学校講座両方使えて
月980円使い放題のことでも安い価格になっておりますよかったぜひ使ってみて
くださいそれじゃあ
スター g サプリ便乗車中
中盤で知覚力はそうなっているのでしょうか後半に入っ
ご期待くださいん